-We don't always
have enough time to cover
all of the recent news,
so here with a recap
is one of our writers
Amber Ruffin
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys!
Things have been crazy.
First of all,
Jay Z joined Instagram,
and I was like --
[ Gasps ] -- "What?"
Then he amassed
2 million followers in one day,
and I was like, "Whaaat?"
Then he quit a day later, and I
was like, "What...a smart move."
[ Laughter ]
Then, Facebook changed its name
to Meta, and I was like,
"What? Meta?
How am I gonna adjust
to this very big name change?
Let me try it out.
Uncle Joe, quit believing
everything you read on Meta!"
Oh, still works.
[ Laughter ]
But I'll tell you
what doesn't work.
My stubborn Uncle Joe.
Then, the emoji council
released a beans emoji,
and I was like, "What?
Council?
There's a whole emoji council?"
I was like, "Yes.
Beans cute, but council?
They all wearing robes
and conjuring up visions
in an orb council?"
[ Laughter ]
Emoji council?
What?
Which one of us got the meaning
for the word "council" wrong?
Council?
As in a council met
and deliberated,
and they came up with this?
It's emojis!
All you need is a 24-year-old
improvisor with a pad and a pen.
Man, that emoji news
had me all like...
[ Laughter ]
And then, I heard Bezos
offered Tom Hanks
a seat on his rocketship
to space.
And I was like, "What?
Tom Hanks
doesn't want to go to space?
That man was in 'Apollo 13,'
and he does not want to go
to space with you."
This man had
to land a plane in the Hudson.
He has no need to go to space.
This man has found true love
with a mermaid.
He does not yearn to wander
to the final frontier.
It makes no sense!
Then, a woman who participated
in the January 6th insurrection
bragged on social media
that she wouldn't go to jail
because she's white with
blonde hair and has a good job,
and I was like, "Whaaaat?"
Every part of that is wrong.
But blonde?
There are
no blonde people in jail?
What?
Paris Hilton went to jail.
Martha Stewart went to jail.
Felicity Huffman,
she went to jail.
And if you told me those
were the only blonde women
to ever go to jail,
I would believe that.
Anyway, that woman was sentenced
to 60 days in jail,
so it's at least
four blonde women in jail.
[ Cheers and applause ]
1, 2, 3, 4 -- 4.
Then I found out
that Kristen Stewart
is getting married!
And I was like, "What fun!"
Then I heard that Guy Fieri
was gonna officiate,
and I was like, "What?
Guy Fieri? What?"
I did not know it was gonna be
a destination wedding
in Flavortown.
I love it!
And that wasn't even the
craziest celebrity wedding news.
Then, Kal Penn
tweeted about being on a plane
and sitting near Cardi B.
and how he wanted her
to officiate his wedding,
and she tweeted she would.
I was like, "What?!"
Because -- true story --
I sat next to Kal
on a flight, too,
and he didn't ask me
to do [bleep]
Then, I found out Aaron Rodgers
got COVID, and I was like,
"This cannot be."
Aaron Rodgers,
the kid I went
to elementary school with?
And they were like,
"No, the Green Bay quarterback,
Aaron Rodgers."
And I was like, "What?"
And then I found out
that he had tricked everyone
into thinking
that he was vaccinated.
And I was like, "Wh-a-a-at?
Finally, football has enough
drama for me."
[ Laughter ]
Just kidding.
This is very bad, and I hate it.
When a reporter
asked if he was vaccinated,
he said he was "immunized."
Now, you know
he was lying right there.
Whenever people use a different
word to answer a question,
it is a telltale sign
they're lying.
"Hey, are you married?"
"You don't see a ring
on my finger, do you?"
"Good enough for me."
[ Laughter ]
Now, to Rodgers' credit,
he may have been lying,
but his whole vibe
was trying to tell us the truth.
Then, in the Virginia governor's
race, there was a commercial
where a mom
tried to get a book banned
because she said it made
her son uncomfortable.
And I was like,
"What are you doing with it?
Is this child
sitting on a book?"
But it turns out
it was a Toni Morrison book.
Now, people are always
trying to get her books
banned from schools,
and I'm always like, "What?"
Stories about the effects
of slavery
make you feel uncomfortable?
Bitch, try living them!"
Then, something utterly
unbelievable happened.
Hundreds of QAnon believers
showed up in Dallas, because --
and this is real --
I did not believe, like,
the first like four articles
I read about it.
But it's true.
They were expecting
to see JFK Jr.
Now, I read this
and was like, "What?!
You were expecting
to see JFK Jr.?
What?
Why did you expect him
to show up,
and what were you expecting?
A man who has not aged?
An old man?
A zombie?
What?
Do you have a sixth sense?
What about senses
one through five?
What?"
[ Laughter ]
"Who was he rolling with?
Santa, the Tooth Fairy,
Genghis Khan?
What are the rules?"
Then I found out
that they thought JFK Jr.
was coming back
to be Trump's running mate.
And I was like, "What?!"
[ Laughter ]
You think a famous Democrat came
back from the dead
to be
the Republican vice president?
A position, by the way, which
almost got the last guy hung?
[ Laughter ]
What?
How do you function
in your day-to-day life?
Because if you start out
waiting for word from somebody
who has been dead since 1999,
you can't possibly run yourself
a bath or open a jar.
[ Laughter ]
How do you send or receive mail?
Do you have a bank account?
[ Laughter ]
What will you do
to keep yourself safe
from misinformation?
Will you take your computer
and throw it into the sun?
Please, take your computer
and throw it into the sun.
Uncle Joe, take your computer
and throw it into the sun!
This has been "Amber Says What?"
[ Cheers and applause ]